Lilly is with us in Arizona hi Lilly how
are you hi Dave I'm good how are you
better than I deserve what's up
ho me and my husband we are first-time
homebuyers and we have just been looking
into different mortgages and trying to
figure out what the best is for us to
renew at this and kind of don't
understand everything so we have two
different loans that we've been offered
and I'm just trying to figure out which
one's best okay so one of them was at an
interest rate of 2.99 but they had
origination fees of $11,000 what size
loan amount
um so 166 is below an amount okay Boyet
and then the other one that they offered
was a 3.8 3% and then we haven't heard a
penny origination fees so my main
question is what our origination fees
and do they charge that for all
mortgages and then is 11,000 high and
not worth getting that low of the
interest rate for high well an
origination there are two things you do
that come into play here origination
fees and points they are calculated the
same way and they do about the same
thing they just go to different people
okay they both are prepaid interest is
what they are in essence so $11,000 you
paid extra so that your interest is
lower because you've already paid some
of your interest that's what it amounts
to now they are calculated this way one
point origination or one point points
either one you paying points plus
origination or points with no
origination or what's called a park whoa
no points no origination but a point is
one percent of loan amount so one point
would be one thousand six hundred and
sixty dollars in your case
okay so 11,000 is a bunch of points in
other words like six now one point
typically will by your interest rate
down your annual percentage rate down by
between 1/8 and 1/4 of a percent so in
other words eight points should equal
about one percent interest rate now you
were quoted to 99 and you were quoted 3
what 8 3 yeah see basically 1 percent
for 8 points so 8 percent of your 166 I
got a front try to find a calculator
here that's working but 0.08 times 166
CB v equals 13,000 so oddly enough they
were charging you about seven points
about about six points in there to get
you not quite a full point of savings so
my math bears out in other words they're
charging you're reducing it around an
eighth of a percent per hundred thousand
hour per per one percent on the interest
is that does that make any sense at all
if you pay eight points let's say you
had a 4% interest rate okay at zero
points of zero rigea nation if you paid
eight points you could get not a 4% but
a 3% that makes sense okay so it's
calculated as one percent a point is one
percent of your loan balance but eight
of them reduces your annual percentage
rate by about one so the bottom line is
if it's an eight it does not make sense
what yours are because if that means it
takes you eight years to recoup this
money you're not gonna get this money
back for eight years with what you're
saving if you could get it back if it
was a fourth you could get it back in
four years you might look at it but
they're charging too much for these
points okay see and that's what I needed
to know so you see how I did that yes I
do see how I did that and I kind of know
alright so called Churchill mortgage and
have them give you a quote a pot it's
called a par quote zero points and zero
origination
I don't know it's it's fairly typical to
pay one point origination and then pay
some points beyond that may be but one
origination doesn't bother me eight or
seven like they're charging you here
they're jacking you around I'll pass on
that company okay and that quote that
quote did not come from Churchill did it
no it could not yeah I didn't say I hope
not but did show you better not really
but it's not a very good offer so yeah
you should be able to get around a 3%
15-year fixed this week somewhere right
around there with one point origination
and no other points okay and do you
think of 15 fixed mortgage is better
than a 30 years yes mortgage the only
thing we ever recommend right Rachel
yeah that's right I mean the faster that
you can pay this house off the better
and some people take a 30 thinking and
having the intention to pay double in
the mortgage because they get the better
interest rate on the 30 versus the 15
but life always happens so just go ahead
and locking in a 15-year fixed with yeah
it's definitely the way to go okay hey
good job good job good question thank
you for joining us